thank you bro i have one rule when you
get a tattoo
don't tell anybody you're getting a
tattoo yeah you don't want their input
if it's what you want you get it and
then deal with the repercussions
afterwards i've never once got a tattoo
and asked my buddies or the internet hey
what do you guys think
you know yeah you got to do it for you
after i got it i messaged you like for
you're like the first person i messaged
yeah mark you have no tattoos i was just
gonna say because you got a body that i
have a secret which is i decided what my
first tattoo was going to be what yeah
do wait do you want to tell your protein
pony
protein is it going to be a jack pony
cherry
i'm definitely going to make a protein
pony your body his body is is
dying oh dude it's crying like it's you
know when you have a really dry plant
and it's dying
and then the soil is crusted and it just
wants to absorb that water oh dude
your arms are dying dude they're a
tapestry
yeah your body's crying it needs that
dude your body's like a homeless guy in
vegas it needs water daddy he needs him
dad it needs hank dude your skin wants
ink he wants to drink ink dude your body
was built for ink
i'm excited so what are we thinking i
never had well i'm i'm going to keep it
a secret remember first rule fight club
yeah
first rule of tattoo clubs
i was going to say i'd never had the ex
i thought about tattoos before and then
like oh good thing i didn't get that i
never had the feeling of like i know
what i want on my body right now and
that it occurred to me the other like a
week ago i was like oh that's that's
what that feeling feels like
can i just speculate what i think you're
gonna get you can put it on record you
ready for this that i think you're gonna
get like the the dna strand of
testosterone
you know those guys they get the
testosterone the molecules
this is the molecule for wind straw
how did you [ __ ] know
how did you [ __ ] with it am i right you
well anavar but yeah yeah
yes that is that's exactly that's wrong
that is funny i [ __ ] called it dude
good i [ __ ]
yeah
you don't have the [ __ ] stones to do
that no but that'd be the greatest one
ever seriously so sick
that animal [ __ ] would be sick
because it actually kind of looks cool
like the angles of it it's like oh
that's not a bad design and then it's
like a joke no i'm into it oh i'm into
it no definitely get that
now here's the thing this is getting a
little dark here i don't know how you're
gonna feel about this you don't wanna
get a tattoo for your dad who passed
away
no i it's like what was your dad i have
um there's symbols that i would get i
wouldn't get a face of his but i would
get like a symbol you know what i mean
other rural fight club yeah i violated
that rule again my sons son's zombies on
my arm yeah and now my son has uh way
shorter here so don't make sense but
here's the thing yeah when you get um
portraits you you you can't like look
for the best deal because oh yeah you'll
get a portrait of your dad who passed
away rest in peace yeah being like oh oh
your dad had down syndrome you're like
no yeah yeah i just made 400 for a
portrait of my father i've seen he's
like
yeah it's either the best thing that's
ever been done no was your dad in a fire
well that was the guy the guy who got a
giant tattoo of poseidon
on his back yeah and it said god of war
you know he's the guy in the sea tits
right yeah what do you mean what did did
and did it have like the poseidon it did
have and it had like the swords and they
looked like this looks like have you
seen that yeah no that's how about brock
lesnar
oh yeah it's brock lesnar he's like you
know what i want a [ __ ] badass sword
and the the artist like say last daddy
and then it gets done he's like
well dude you put a giant [ __ ] on my
chest let me see yeah
like he didn't mean to
but
the way he did the top is the spear
you know like there's you should have
made it sharper you should make it
sharper though right sharper and i'm not
crazy about that terrible sword but it
is brock lesnar